SERGE LACHAPELLE: I'll just
introduce everyone once,
so we won't have to do it.
I'm Serge, product
lead on Chrome WebRTC.
This is my partner in crime,
Justin, who's tech lead.
Sam works with me very
closely, he runs dev rel,
so developer relations, for
Chrome Media, based in London.
Pangu.
Hi, Pangu.
The guy with the long name.
Pangu.
works with WebM, so
the VP codecs and such.
So he's going to bring you a
little bit of his knowledge
to us here.
And Dimitri has the fun job.
Dmitri is going to
start off by bringing
in a little bit of
Google I/O here.
And so we'll try to
get a demo going.
You might have heard
about cardboard.
And Dmitriy and Pangu built
something pretty amazing
on their own time,
or on the side,
for Google I/O using
cardboard and WebRTC.
So I'll leave the
honors to them.
PANGU: Do you want
me to explain,
or do you want to explain?
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Yeah.
PANGU: Cool.
So hi.
My name is Pangu, I also go
as the guy with the long name.
And I work on the WebM project
as well as video on Chrome.
And Dmitriy is one of the
engineers who I work with.
And Dmitriy has
done an amazing job.
So I shouldn't take any
credit whatsoever other
than sort of helping
him get here.
So yeah, what we've sort of
done is-- how many of you
heard of Cardboard yesterday,
or like through I/O?
All right.
How many of you
find it interesting?
A lower number.
We were fascinated
with virtual reality.
So we had planned another
demo for I/O. Essentially
we wanted to get a quadcopter
and a submarine connected
using about WebRTC channels
so that people could control
these things in different
parts of the world.
And then we heard of Cardboard.
And then we were like,
OK, scrap everything.
We have to work on this.
Because we found it so exciting.
And the idea in the
heart of Cardboard
was that you are getting
an Android SDK so that you
can build apps which
will automatically
take care of virtual reality
and all that stuff for you.
And then we thought,
why not the web?
This should be as easy to code
for the web for virtual reality
as it is for Android.
And we sort of started
off with that mission,
saying the web should be a great
platform for virtual reality
end that's what we try to do.
So it's going to be a
little bit hard to demo
without the Cardboard
in your face.
And unfortunately I
don't have a, ooh, look
under your seats moment today.
So sorry about that.
We tried.
But I have to show
you one thing.
So we made a couple of things.
The first one is this little
rower, who we called Dmitriy.
And Dmitriy is a rower
that can be controlled
over the WebRTC data
channels for both motion
as well as this 3-D camera
right in front of here.
And what they did
was we piped this
through-- a little bit of a hack
to make WebRTC work with it.
But essentially, what
we did was the video
goes through an Arduino board
as well as this XP transmitter
and transmits to a
video capture card,
which we've sort of hidden away
right there so that you don't
have to see how the
sausage is made.
And once the sausage is made,
though, it's really tasty.
Because as you can do is
set this up right here.
And I'm going to do a live
test to see if this works.
All right.
Dmitriy.
So what Dmitriy
is doing right now
is actually looking
through the cardboard.
And his eyes are sort of placed
onto this particular camera.
And it moves as
with the Cardboard.
It can also be controlled.
As we were testing this, we
worked with Justin's team
up in Seattle.
And Zeek, another
developer there,
he was able to control this
while watching up in Seattle.
And all thanks
because of WebRTC.
So you're going to
put it right here.
Go ahead.
So as it goes, Dmitriy
can see what's going on.
And no, these are
not killer robots.
This is a very fun
little Dmitriy robot.
So what we'll have
is we'll have this
set up here so that during the
break a few of you can come
and check it out, if
you're interested.
And yeah, I'll let the show go
on and I'll come back later.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Thank you.
There is one great
thing with Dmitriy,
is that he feels no motion
sickness whatsoever.
I tried this for a few
minutes, and after a while
you get pretty busy.
So thank you.
This is just an example of,
with a little bit of time,
a little bit of knowledge, and
a bunch of open source code,
what you can achieve.
And you can build things that
are completely surprising.
I have not seen this
before going to Google I/O,
and I was completely surprised.
So thanks guys.
All right.
Now Justin.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Sorry, I just
want to sort of-- check, check.
I just want to sort of
add to what Serge just
said right there.
That if you'd asked me three
years ago, when we first
came up with the
idea for WebRTC,
would we use it to
basically pretend
like we're in virtual reality
while we're driving a race car?
I would've been quite surprised.
But we've built this
really strong platform
that's really malleable.
And it was very, very easy
for Dmitriy and his team,
and in a whole different office,
to get this all up and running.
We even had it
running over AppRTC,
so that you could connect
AppRTC, have the thing.
And someone in our
office in Seattle
could actually drive the car.
So we could take the
technology and very quickly
go after new opportunities.
That's one of the things I'm
most excited about WebRTC.
So anyway, on the platform,
we've been hard at work
on a ton of things.
I made this little
tag cloud here,
just sort of talking
about the stuff we've
done in the past 18 months.
You can go through
all these things.
But your eyes may start
hurting after a while,
because there's a ton
of stuff on there.
But I do like coming
to these events
and sharing our road maps.
Because some of the things that
people tell us is, you know,
we've been waiting
for feature x.
And I'd say, well, we
actually implemented that
three months ago.
Or we've been
waiting to do this,
but we didn't know
this was coming.
And so I really like
being able to go out
and say, here's what
we're working on,
here is we're trying to do.
And if there's things that
aren't on the road map,
well I like to sort of
hear, what are we missing?
So that was stuff we did
over the past 18 months.
Here's kind of where we
are with Chrome 36, which
is going to go into stable,
I think, in two weeks.
And then Chrome 37, which
is sort of later on in Q3.
And so, I'm not going to
spend a ton of time going
into every single
thing, because we
have actually a lot of
content for you today.
But if you have questions of
anything and hear it in detail,
please come up and
catch one of us later.
But one of the big things
we've heard from people
is that trying to do an HD
video, or even video on mobile,
people say the video
quality is not very good.
And they say it's the codec.
Or they say it's WebRTC.
And it turns out, in many
cases, it's the network.
And the way that video
works over IP networks
is that you kind of have to play
this sort of black magic game
of guessing how much
capacity the network has.
There's no API where you can
say, how much bandwidth do you
support?
Because it's fully dynamic.
It changes based
on how many people
are using the network, how
much load is on the thing.
And it can even depend on what
kind of network type it is.
So you have to do
this sort of thing
where you do these probes.
Or you set a bunch of data, and
you sort of see, did that work?
Now I can send a
little more data.
What ends up happening
is that if you end up
making bad guesses about
what the network can support,
you either under
use the network--
meaning it takes forever and
the video bit rate is very low.
Typically for HD
stream, you want one
to two megabits of video.
And if you're predicting
less than that,
you have a very chunky,
blocky, grainy video.
Looks terrible.
If you overuse the network,
things are even worse.
Because the video just
turns black and it freezes.
AUDIENCE: Kills your audio.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah, exactly.
You get robot voice.
So getting bandwidth
estimation right,
it's a very hard problem.
There's probably some people
in the audience who've
worked on this problem in
and know what's involved.
So we've been very
hard at work on this.
We want to make sure
that we can make
these scenarios on my
Cardboard work great.
And these require
things that are
more than just HD resolution.
We're going past
720p, past 1080p.
You know, 4K type resolution.
And if you're going to be
sending 5, 10 megabits of video
over the network, you
better be able to ramp up
to that sort of
level very quickly.
So in Chrome 36, we have an
all new bandwidth estimation
algorithm that is much
better about analyzing
the sort of peculiarities of
Wi-Fi and ramps up faster,
avoids mispredicting
in many cases.
If you're doing HD
streams on Chrome 36,
you should see much
better HD quality.
You should see it faster, you
should see it more stable.
We've also been
trying to make sure
that screen casting, the
ability to share your screen
and have that image be
distributed to the world,
works great.
And there are a couple issues
we had in previous versions
where, when we had a
big scene transition,
we would generate
a very big video
frame that could be
like 50, 70k of data.
And when we tried to put that
data on a network all at once,
we would basically
crush the network.
You can lose packets.
You end up with a long delay,
and it would take a long time
from the time you put a new
slide on the screen to the time
people could actually see that.
We spent a lot of time
tuning this, fixing it.
It now works a lot better
in 36, even better in 37.
So now, you should see that
screen sharing performance
has improved substantially.
I talked to the Screenhero
guys just today.
And we really want a
screen sharing applications
to be first class citizens
in the WebRTC ecosystem.
And if you're not seeing
the performance where
it's working great for you,
we want to hear from you.
Just a few other things we had.
We now automatically
will back down,
if we're on a low power
machine, and we're kind of
over driving the CPU.
We're trying to send like
HD quality or something.
We can now back that down
and send a lower resolution
automatically if we detect that
we're over driving the CPU.
This is what we
call CPU adaptation.
New NetEq is our
adaptive gen buffer,
it's more efficient for stereo.
And a bunch of
things on the data
channels to be fully spec
and protocol compliant.
On the 37 side-- so 37
just went through cut
and is going to dev channel,
or will be beta very soon.
One thing we've heard
consistently from developers
is that the bar that comes
down on the top of the screen,
asking for Chrome to use your
camera, is too hard to see.
And then we know this,
because every single app puts
in their own "hey, look
at this thing up here"
in the user interface.
That tells us we're
not doing a good job.
So we've been working
on this for a while.
And whenever you do something
like this in Chrome,
it's like you can't just
replace the thing for WebRTC,
it's like we have to go and
rework the entire permissions
request experience
across geolocation,
WebRTC, everything.
Well--
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
And you have to do it
across Windows,
Mac, Linux, Android.
And you have to do
it for, as Justin
said, geolocation,
offline content,
all the permissions that a
web browser needs to ask.
So it turns out that this
is a huge undertaking.
And having all that previously
reviewed and approved
and security reviewed and
approved takes a long time.
But finally, we're
getting there.
And you should start seeing
this in Chrome 37 soon.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Finally.
Yes.
So your users should
all benefit from this.
[APPLAUSE]
And hopefully your
poor HTML developers
will not have to spend time
aligning pixels for like, point
to the allow button.
Some other things are
retransmission of packets.
We now follow RFC properly.
And we also have now
adaptive opus FEC.
So if you turn on the Use
in-band FEC parameter in SDP--
it's not on by default right
now, we hope to fix that in 38.
We will look at the
packet loss that's
occurring on the connection,
and we'll turn up FEC
based on what
actually we encounter.
So if your network
connection is great,
then no FEC will be used.
If your network connection
starts to suffer,
we'll start basing
encoding redundant copies
of the audio packets
when using opus,
to make sure that if
you have some dropouts,
that the conversation
is still intelligible.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: And
that's what FEC stands for.
Forward Error Correction,
for the web developers here.
It means you sort of send
out copies of the audio.
In case one of the
copy gets lost,
you have another
one that came in.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah.
I'm going to use a
ton of acronyms here--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JUSTIN UBERTI: Opus has
support for automatically,
but the codec does not
do it automatically.
It needs a source
basically indicating
that, here's what the
actual packet loss is.
And since we also have our
own packet loss concealment
inside NetEq, we had to
do a bunch of integration
between that PLC and
the opus FEC processing.
So you are correct, in that
Opus does support does natively.
By making this work
inside WebRTC and Chrome
was a substantial
engineering project.
Otherwise it would
have worked already.
So one other thing
is on Mac, we're
supporting AV
foundation in Chrome 37.
So previously, the thing you
used to open camera devices
was something
called QTKit, which
had its own sort
of peculiarities.
And that was the old and busted.
And [INAUDIBLE] is
the new hotness.
So you should see better,
more stable-- just
in our crash rates we can see
this-- performance in Chrome 37
on Mac.
So looking forward.
We continue to make
significant investments
in bandwidth estimation.
We want to make sure
we can ramp up faster.
Currently it takes-- what
was it Serge, to get to HD?
15 seconds?
SERGE LACHAPELLE: 15, 20.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah.
We still feel that's too long.
We're providing APIs that allow
you to set the start-bit rate.
So if you're on like a
LAN or dedicated network,
you could start
out closer to HD.
But in order to get
up to 4K, we want
to make sure you can
start higher and ramp up
faster and make sure
that, in all these cases,
we're never over
driving the network.
We also have some
work being done
to vastly improve
echo cancellation.
To be much more
tolerant of the cases
where the operating
system does not
give us reliable delay values.
The delay value is a
very important part
of echo cancellation,
to know how
much longer and
further in time you
should expect the reflected
signal to come back in,
after it was played out
of the speakers, back
to the microphone.
In some cases, it very easy
to tell, because the OS
tells us immediately how much
data, how much time there is.
In other cases, you kind
of have to guess at it.
We're working on
improving things,
so that we can do a great job
even when we need to guess.
We're also adding
new APIs to add
per stream control of
things like bit rate.
That if you're sending
in multiple streams,
you might want to
say, this one, we
want to send in HD, and this
one, we want to send in QVGA.
Because you want to send maybe
a screen share plus your image.
In the past, we didn't really
have these kind of controls.
We only had these very high
level constraints types things.
We couldn't say,
hey, set the bit rate
for this one particular stream.
And we're adding a new set of
APIs called RTC, RTP Sender,
and RTC, RTP Receiver,
which basically gives you
a new thing in the object
model that gives you per stream
and coding control.
This will be useful
in WebRTC 1.0
for things like
bit rate control.
And addition things
in WebRTC 1.1,
which I'll talk about
in a little bit.
Another thing
we've heard from is
people wanted the ability to
set what audio output device is
being used.
This is a very complicated
security and usability
sort of thing.
But we know people want this.
We're working very hard on it.
And a bunch of stuff
on the ISE side.
Being able to limit
yourself to only using
relay candidates for
privacy and other privacy
preserving techniques.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: So I'll
let you catch your breath
and do the rest here.
VP 9, we've talked about it.
Pangu will talk
about it in a minute.
Very important for us.
We're going to start
experimenting with VP 9
in a way that you
can also try it out.
It's a better video codec.
I won't talk too much
about it right now.
Noise reduction.
Little, little tiny
cameras are super noisy.
They're not very precise, they
have a very small sensor size.
So the image they produce
is often very noisy.
And cleaning out that
image in real time,
turns out there's a quite
complex mathematical problem
that we are tackling.
And hopefully, you will
see the benefits of this
before the end of the year.
Media stream recorder.
The number one voted
Chromium feature request.
By far, for our team.
So we are absolutely
going to tackle that.
And you will also see
the results of this
before the end of the year.
We've been using SCTP
for our data channel API.
We are going to
start experimenting
with QUIC, instead.
QUIC is an experimental--
JUSTIN UBERTI: In addition.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: In
addition, right, not instead.
We won't be
experimenting with SCTP.
And this is going to be
an interesting project.
And hopefully we will be able
to see much better network
performance from data channels
using this new network stack.
And we are refactoring
the way Chrome does audio.
You're going to see us move
critical components more
or less outside of
WebRTC and inside Chrome.
So for example, if you're
watching a YouTube video,
and you're in a
WebRTC audio chat,
the audio from the YouTube video
won't go back into your chat
through the speakers.
So we'll be able to do sort of
system wide echo cancellation.
And we're going to start
doing this a lot more,
so that Chrome
can take advantage
of the WebRTC components.
And WebRTC developers can take
advantage of these components
Chrome-wide.
So that's also planned
for the end of the year.
And before we go on.
It's important to mention
that we base this road map,
and we plan our work--
we're a small team-- we
plan our work very carefully.
And we plan it based on
the feedback you give us.
So sometimes I'll
go to Twitter, and I
will look at the WebRTC hashtag.
And I'll see people
complain about x or y.
But that's like
screaming out in space.
If you want us to hear
some of your pain,
some of your questions,
some of your concerns,
this is a much better place
to go and share them with us
than the WebRTC hashtag or
just the usual complaining.
Because we really do listen,
and we really sit down
with these things super
frequently and plan
our work through these tools.
So the Chromium tracker,
the WebRTC tracker,
and the discuss WebRTC
list are your friends.
Thank you.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Couldn't
have said it better myself.
I mean, we look at these
bugs by how many stars
they have and say, what are
the things that are really
causing pain to developers?
And just over the course of the
past quarter, when I generated
this list, we ticked off,
I think, about 70 to 80%
of these bugs.
So again, if there's something
that's causing an issue,
please file it.
You can send us an email,
bring it to our attention.
But otherwise,
it's just very hard
to know what is
holding people back.
I also just want to talk
briefly about mobile support.
I talked about Chrome.
And we're doing a fantastic
job on Chrome for Android.
You may have seen some
of the things that
are new in L, where
webpages become
really peers of native apps.
Basically, every web page
is in the recents view
of your test
switcher on Android.
Now every webpage is a
peer with a native app.
So you can have a page
that basically acts just
like an application.
That's a great sort of fit
for a WebRTC app on Chrome
for Android.
But it talks about
a few other things.
Also in the L
runnings of Android,
both web audio and WebRTC
are fully supported.
So if you're
building a native app
and want to be able to use
these technologies from web,
you can now do that
using web view.
And that's going to be part
of Chrome WebView v 36.
Another thing that's-- this is
not really Android specific,
but it really comes
up a lot on Android--
is tuning our bandwidth
estimation to deal with
cellular networks.
We found that with Wi-Fi, Wi-Fi
has a lot of interesting packet
patterns.
Turns out, not only
is it not a truck,
it's also not a series
of tubes, either.
So we're doing a
lot of things just
in looking at what the
networks are actually
doing with the data to make sure
that video really works well.
Y'all may have also
heard, 64-bitness.
There's a iPhone 5
supporting 64-bit.
Android is also going
to support 64-bit,
and we want to make
sure WebRTC works
great, is fully optimized
for 64-bit scenarios.
I've talked about video hardware
acceleration a bit in the past.
The Android K release
was the first release
to have VP8 exposed
in the media codec API
that's usable for real time.
We're continuing
to iterate on that.
Make sure it can be used
for doing multiple encodes
at the same time, multiple
decodes at the same time.
Really respect proper bit rate
changing, that sort of thing.
And work across a
variety of vendors.
K was mostly Qualcomm
and Snapdragon 800.
We're making sure
this works really
well across a variety
of other chip makers,
including Samsung,
Invidia, et cetera.
To basically make sure
you can get HD quality
without being CP
unlimited, because you
can offload a lot of
stuff to the DSP block.
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
An interesting fact
is that, for example, the Chrome
OS ChromeBook 2 by Samsung
fully supports encode
and decode of VP8
in hardware for any
WebRTC app out of the box.
JUSTIN UBERTI: You may
have heard the Android 1
announcement at Google I/O.
Basically there's a reference
platform for kind of low
cost Android devices.
We're going to make sure the
WebRTC stack works really well
on Android 1 as well.
While we do have
Chrome for Android,
as a platform for
WebRTC, we also
support as a first class citizen
basically the Java native API.
It's peerconnection.java.
And we'll continue to make sure
that peerconnection.java keeps
in sync with the new APIs that
are being added, as I mentioned
on the previous page, for
RTP Sender and Receiver
and that sort of thing.
On the iOS side, we're doing a
number of just catch up things,
making sure we have the full
set of APIs available on iOS.
Data channels is probably
the biggest thing
that's missing right now.
And I was just thought the
developer working on this,
they're trying to get this
working as soon as possible.
I think within the
next couple weeks,
we should have full
support including
SETB data channels on iOS.
And another interesting
thing is just
iOS has a bunch of great
APIs for accessing the GPU.
Looking into what
kind of hardware
offload we can do
for VPA processing
on iOS, as well as
for camera capture.
So Alex mentioned
the state AppRTC.
And we've also been aware
of some the problems
he mentioned as far
as message delivery.
You would think
that kind of getting
like a message from
point A to point B
would be a soft problem in 2014.
It turns out that this is
actually very complicated.
As Alex sort of
went into detail on,
we are going to be overhauling
the back end of AppRTC
to use some of the new
technologies available on App
Engine to make it
the way faster, way
better about preserving
things like ordering,
and that just way more reliable.
So if you're using
App RTC as kind
of a base for your
application, we
should have a lot
of things that will
make joining our
call much faster.
And reliability, just like we
want that to 100% of the time,
it shouldn't have anything
where the message got delivered
in the wrong order and you had
to fix it up on the client.
You shouldn't have
to worry about that.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Depending on
when we get booted off stage
by Tahee, we might have a
demo of an upcoming version.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Right.
And we also are working
to make AppRTC, Sam
here, our tireless dev
rel advocate for WebRTC,
is working on making
it fully mobile.
So it works great on Nexus
7, it works great on Nexus 5,
works great on basically any
browser that supports WebRTC.
So that's long overdue,
and we're very much
looking forward to
that being done.
Now we also talked about turn
a little bit before and about
how we do the load
balancing for turn.
If you go to my GitHub,
GitHub [INAUDIBLE],
there's a project called
Compute Engine on Demand.
And that's a thing I've talked
about before, where we spool up
GCE instances that are running
on RFC 57, 76 TURN server.
You can clone that, hack on it.
That's the secret
sauce you mentioned.
It's not secret anymore.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Did
you just release it now?
JUSTIN UBERTI: It was in
[INAUDIBLE] GitHub before.
It was undiscovered.
It was the obscure
sauce, if you will.
But the part that's
even better about this
is that-- the fact that you
even have to do this all on GC
is kind of crap.
GC should do this for you.
That and basically if you have
TURN load that's increasing,
you should be able to seamlessly
and elastically scale up
your TURN clusters.
And there's a thing
called GC replica pools.
And replica pools
already are really
good about scaling
up based on CPU.
So if you're using GC replica
pools for your TURN server,
you're already kind
of half the way there.
And we're pushing on the
GC team to add replica pool
support where they can scale
up based on bandwidth, which
is kind of what you really,
really want for turn.
So long story short, you
have Compute Engine on Demand
for doing this now.
But I'm hoping that the GC
infrastructure will also
do all the heavy lifting
for us later this year.
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
And lastly, you're
going to see us pay
down technical debt.
Which means cleaning up
APIs, removing old code,
moving to newer APIs,
a ton of refactoring.
So things are going to change
a lot in the code base,
for the better.
This helps us make Chrome
more responsive, helps us make
our developers, our engineers,
much more productive.
And so as you tag along
with us on this journey,
you're going to see
some churn there.
And if you're wondering
what's going on, a lot of it
is about paying
down technical debt
to make sure we don't become
a huge bloated platform.
JUSTIN UBERTI: An
example of this
is just what Serge mentioned
about the rewrite of how
audio processing is being
done inside of Chrome.
And when we get to sort
of the promised land,
not only will we have full
browser echo cancellation,
but we'll also have the ability
to apply web audio effects
on received media coming
in on a peer connection.
The spec.
OK.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: I did that.
[LAUGHTER]
JUSTIN UBERTI:
That's very clever.
Yes.
Sometimes I do feel this way.
So I want to just talk about
some of the big issues.
A lot of questions,
and some information I
think that might be alarming
some people incorrectly.
I want to set the record
straight on some things.
getUserMedia,
we're trying to get
this to working group last call.
So we're very close,
but there still
are some things where there's
still arguing going on,
on exactly how you specify,
I want this resolution,
but not this resolution.
I'm hoping this
will get worked out,
and we get this spec to
last call later this year
and consider this done.
WebRTC 1.0.
So WebRTC 1.0 is basically
taking the peer connection spec
and getting that to last call.
Where we feel like we have
the features we need for 1.0,
it doesn't mean that WebRTC
never moves forward past 1.0.
But there's a consistent,
complete set of APIs
that can be supported
across browsers,
and developers know
what they can expect.
They can get
deterministic behavior.
And I'm hoping that we can
get at least to working
group on last call of WebRTC
1.0 spec later this year.
And so that leads into,
well, what happens past 1.0?
And what is this thing I've
heard about called ORTC?
Is ORTC going to replace WebRTC?
Do I need to
rewrite all my code?
Is this going to
be a sort of schism
between the two
churches of WebRTC?
I want to head that
off and say ORTC
will be integrated
into WebRTC 1.1.
There's already a
bunch of concepts
that I talked about earlier.
RTP Sender, RTP Receiver.
These are concepts that
originated within ORTC
and have been very definitely
woven into the WebRTC 1.0
specification.
So ORTC was kind of over
here, and WebRTC 1.0 was here,
or 0.9 was here.
And we kind of moved
WebRTC in this direction.
We're ORTC in this direction.
So what you're going to
get is your existing code
is going to keep on working.
You're going to get more
knobs to tune things.
And if you don't want to deal
with the high level things,
you want to go right
down to the low level
and handle all the settings
and stuff like that,
you can do that.
So it's like the
best of both worlds.
Your existing code works,
you get more stuff.
And if you're a
rock star expert who
wants to really
have all control,
you're going to get that too.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: So a
normal evolution, basically.
Like Justin said, there's been
a little bit of FUD around this.
JUSTIN UBERTI: ORTC and WebRTC
are an evolution of-- 1.1
is an evolution of WebRTC 1.0.
Not a French Revolution with
guillotines and all that.
OK.
So codecs.
This is another
thing that causes
no shortage of controversy.
And I want to just articulate
what the Chrome position is
on some of these things.
And then we're going to have
a fantastic update on VP9
specifically, from Pangu.
So first, VP8.
The short story is VP7 is
Google's codec of choice.
We think this is the right
codec for the open web platform.
We think this is the
right codec for WebRTC.
We are trying to get
this in as many hardware
places as possible.
Across Android, across
Chrome, making this hardware
accelerated, getting
the best performance
for screen sharing,
for HD, for 4K.
VP8 is the codec
of now, and we're
going to make sure that
it's successful for people
who are using it.
So H.264.
Some folks have asked us--
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Boo.
JUSTIN UBERTI: So I just
mentioned the position
that we have.
But some folks have
asked us, well,
can I submit a
patch to add H.264
into the WebRTC code base?
And we're not ideologues here.
So there's a patch.
We're working on integrating it.
If you want to ship
H.264 support where
you bring your own H.264
from Joe's H.264 store,
then you're certainly
welcome to do that.
And we will have the
packetization support
in WebRTC, the negotiation
support, where that can work.
But it won't be in Chrome.
So if you want to build
your own application using
the WebRTC source code,
H.264 can be supported.
You can integrate
it very easily.
But as I mentioned,
we think the VP8
is the right choice
for the web platform.
But we think the even better
choice, starting next year,
will be VP9.
And I'm going to hand it over
to Pangu to regal us on--
PANGU: Was that a subtle
dig that both of them
were in black and white
and this is a color?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Well,
it's, you know, 9.
It's at least 1.25 times better.
Or .125.
PANGU: So before I get started
on VP9, a couple [INAUDIBLE].
First is unfortunately,
Dmitriy has to leave.
But Instructions on how to
build this will be coming up
on g.co/chromevr.
We already have a bunch of
Chrome experiments there
that already works
with Cardboard.
So if you have a Cardboard, you
should totally check that out.
And if you don't
have a Cardboard,
you can actually build
your own at g.co/cardboard.
There's chromatic set up there.
So VP9.
One of the things
that we got started
as we were thinking
about codecs was,
this is from a company
called Sandvine.
And they do this
stage of the internet
roughly twice every year.
And this is from the
second half of 2013.
And it shows what are the
different activities that
happen over the internet.
And you'll see that 61%
of peak internet bandwidth
is taken over by
video streaming.
And this is across
the VOD streaming
as well as any form of video
conferencing, et cetera.
So we saw that number
a couple years.
At that point it was
close to 50% percent.
And that just scared us.
Because it clearly showed that
global internet bandwidth was
not growing at a pace
that was keeping up
with how much video is being
consumed over the internet.
And so, I should have probably
led with this question.
Who here knows of VP9?
All right.
Whoa.
That's a low number.
So let me give you a quick
introduction with respect
to what we did to
solve this problem.
Our goal was, if we put a
little bit more compute cycles,
how much more can we
actually compress the video?
And I sort of really,
really do injustice
to the technology
that goes in by sort
of calling it compute cycles.
But there's a lot
of decisions that
can be made at the
time of encoding.
And as with Moore's law,
as we get a little bit
more compute cycles,
we can actually
compress the video further.
And that's been the theory
behind you video codecs.
And with VP9 we just
look it one step higher.
With a little bit
more compute cycles,
you can actually get now
up to 50% compression
for the same quality.
Usually I run a video,
to show that-- I
show a H.264 clip and a VP9
clip, and we have roughly 50%.
I'll actually send links
instead, along with the e-mail,
along with all these things.
So over the past year-- we
announced VP9 in June 2013.
And since then, we've
been working hard
to ensure that
YouTube runs on VP9.
It was not an easy sell.
It was a really,
really hard sell.
And I'll tell you what were
the benefits that we got.
Because we were really trying
hard to sell to YouTube.
But the first one
is that, I wanted
to give you an idea of what
YouTube is in its current form
today.
So YouTube has over a
billion monthly active users.
It deals with over 6
billion hours of video
on a monthly basis.
100 hours of video are uploaded
into YouTube every minute,
and that's increasing.
[LAUGHTER]
And 80% of the traffic
that comes to YouTube
comes from outside of the USA.
And YouTube did a
really, really hard job
of making sure that
H.264 works for them.
And we were going to
them and telling, hey,
we've got this new,
happy, fancy, new codec.
Why don't you start
using that instead?
And they were like,
nope, hold your horses.
We want to see what
the performance is,
what the benefits
are, et cetera.
And so instead of leading
with how we did what we did,
I wanted to show you one
more data point from YouTube.
Which was, on the left--
or, wait, that's the right.
On the right, you have the
uploaded videos in 2010
in YouTube.
And the uploaded videos
in 2013 in YouTube.
And that's roughly a 600%
increase that they saw.
And then you could also see,
from 2008 onwards, what's
been 720p and greater
uploads on YouTube.
Unfortunately, we can't
give you the numbers,
but this is one of
those Bezos charts.
It just goes up.
So we somehow imagined that
we somehow convinced VP9,
it was a lot of hypnotizing.
And then they were
like, OK, cool.
VP9 works.
That's actually start
re-encoding the entire YouTube
catalog in VP9, and we'll
start with the popular ones.
And this includes 4K as well.
And you'll see that the
top chart is calling out
what is known as the format
distribution in YouTube.
So YouTube needs to maintain
a 240p video, a 360p video,
a 480p video, a 720p video,
a 1080p video, a 4K video,
and all the other
ones in between,
to make sure that we give
you a great streaming
performance in YouTube.
So [INAUDIBLE]
distribution is one
of the biggest
challenges for YouTube.
Now imagine that now
you need to feed this
across all the caches
across the world.
What do you keep, and
how do you keep it?
Et cetera.
And with VP9, our
goal was, if you
can encode the video
in VP9, we will just
have the bit rate overall.
And as a result of
that, you should
be able to store more content
and egress more content.
And that's where
you sort of see.
Another one with no
numbers shows you
how the format
distribution changed.
And think of this as 1080p,
720p, 480p, 360p, 240p, et
cetera.
That's the amount of
storage that they contain,
and how we've shrunken
that down for YouTube.
I won't bore you with this.
So why YouTube keeps
these various formats
is also so that we can
adapt the video for you,
so that you get a much
better streaming experience.
And with HTML5 we
added MSE to make sure
that YouTube can take advantage
of this adapted streaming.
And using that as well as dash,
what we've been able to do
is sort of give you a really
fast streaming experience.
And you can do this on your own.
Go to YouTube today.
In your hopefully crappy Wi-Fi
connection, and hopefully
that's not true.
But with less than
1 BPS, earlier you
could barely stream
480p content on YouTube
without encountering
the rebuffer circle.
Today, you can stream 720p if
that video is encoded in VP9.
And it will be a pretty
smooth experience.
It's not, file a bug.
And how you can check if that
particular video is VP9 or not
is you can right
click on the player.
And you can see a thing
called stats for nerds,
and then you can see
what's the MIME type
for that particular video.
It should say VP9.
So in order to
convince YouTube-- let
me just see if I have
some more numbers here.
So YouTube adopted VP9.
And today, more than 60% of
daily playbacks on Chrome
are done using dash VP9.
And this has had a
tremendous benefit for them.
And some of the
numbers that I want
to highlight but I
couldn't get it in
were-- the first
one is, overall,
worldwide, now you see 25% more
HD video content as a result.
And they load 15%
percent faster.
And this is because we've been
able to reduce the bit rate.
Because the codec provides
that corresponding benefit.
Along with that is also the
fact that we made VP9 really,
really fast, so that YouTube
can actually use this.
So we've added
multiple points now
between the computational
efficiency and the compression
efficiency that
you wanted to do,
so that VP9 can be used
by YouTube and the like,
as well as with RTC.
So you'll see that this
is a VPN speed parameter
chart that we use.
Which is-- think of speed 0
as kind of the kitchen sink,
where we use all the encode
tools and consume as much
of your CPU resources
as possible.
And with every
step, we have tried
to give you a slightly
lower compassion efficiency,
but a much faster
performance from VP9.
So you have to sort
of read it as, if you
use speed 1 over speed 0 of
VP9, it'll be seven times more
faster.
And you'll get roughly 95 off
the compression efficiency
that you would have had
if you had used speed 0.
And the jump at speed 5.
It says that it's 57 times
faster than speed 0 is.
So that speed 5 are
our beginning target
that we're trying
to look for WebRTC.
So roughly 5% speed
efficiency drop
for a speed increase
at the speed 4.
And at the beginning
of this year,
when we started working on
the real-time mode for VP9,
we were 25 times
slower than real time.
Which means that for every
frame that you need to encode,
that's what?
It's too high.
Too high.
And today, we are at a point
where we can now give you
roughly, for 2.2 times real
time speed, we can give you
significant
compression efficiency.
But we've added a little
bit more speeds here.
And I don't have a chart there.
So we have two speeds
right now in VP9
that this function is that
you can test for your time.
The first is at speed 5, which
is roughly 2.2x and gives you
40% compression efficiency.
And speed 6, very roughly
40% more CPU cycles,
but it gives you 20%
compression efficiency over VP8.
We've started testing
this in certain cases.
So for example, we have
together a Chrome remote desktop
experience with VP9.
The visual quality
is phenomenal.
And for text, especially, we've
added I444 experimental support
as well.
You can see almost
lostless text rendering.
And for that extra 40% more
we see roughly 20% gains
in compression efficiency.
We are very confident
that we'll get it
to you by the end of this year,
as Serge mentioned earlier.
And just wanted to give you
a quick note on the adoption.
Today they're on Android,
Chrome, Firefox, and Opera.
And more than a billion devices
can already play VP9 today.
If they are part of
the media codec APIs,
from KitKat onwards, and we'll
have some more stuff for L.
I think that's it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
SERGE LACHAPELLE: 60% of
all YouTube videos on Chrome
are using VP9.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah.
So we're talking about
millions upon millions
upon millions of
minutes every day, VP9.
And compare that to HEVC.
I think that we're in a
very nice place for VP9.
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
Thank you, Pangu.
Thank you very much.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Thank you.
So again, the future.
And let's talk about current
day adoption of WebRTC.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: And
we'll have to be quick,
because time is running out,
and we have some fun stuff
to talk about.
JUSTIN UBERTI: You
want to take this?
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Yeah.
So we're tracking over
300 companies that
are deploying WebRTC
technology today.
And in fact, I
think Tahee's going
to say that that
number is wrong.
AUDIENCE: 450.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: 450 now?
So if you're doing anything
with WebRTC, talk to this guy
so you get tracked.
We've got about 1.7 billion
WebRTC enabled devices.
That's our estimate by
the end of the year,
if you include all the mobile
phones, all the desktop,
the penetration of the
HTML5 capable browsers
that support WebRTC.
And wow, where did
that number come from?
2018.
Up and to the right.
All right.
So basically even dogs will
be running-- but just to say.
Like we have
watches, we're going
to have all these devices that
are going to be around us.
And these devices
are going to be
built on top of the
same kind of technology
that we have in our phones,
that we have in our laptops.
And so the WebRTC
experience, right?
It's going to be in the
remote-control cars.
You can imagine
this being the gift
of the year for Christmas
this year, or next year.
And so as the hardware
becomes commoditized
and the open software finds
its way on all that hardware,
this is not a hard
thing to believe.
So I'm looking forward to 2018.
JUSTIN UBERTI: This
is current day.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Current day.
JUSTIN UBERTI: These
are not projections,
these are real stats.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: We've got
300 million 30-day actives
on Chrome for Android.
We have Chrome and Firefox
interopping, and Opera.
And this is not just sort of a
you make a blog post, woohoo,
we've achieved interop, and
then you go forward in life.
We actually do integrated tests.
So on a daily basis, there
are hundreds and hundreds
of calls made by our test bots.
They bring up a virtual Firefox,
they bring up a virtual Chrome,
and they place calls
between each other.
We're trying very, very hard to
maintain this interoperability
and we're working closely
with the Firefox team.
And this is also a
testament to the standards
community that are
helping us out with this.
I don't know if you want to talk
about the under consideration
for Internet Explorer?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah.
Just coming back
to the ORTC point,
there's a
status.modern.IE-- basically
IE's current proposed
future support
for a bunch of web technologies.
And Microsoft has
said on that site
that they are currently
looking at supporting ORTC.
My expectation, based
on just intuition,
is that we should see
WebRTC support coming
in Internet Explorer very soon.
I can't speak for our friends
in Cupertino right now,
but nobody wants to
be the only person
not invited to the party, so.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: We
talked about this.
I guess we can just skip it.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Well,
you know, 1 billion.
They're Android 30-day actives.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Huge thing.
Lots of work went into this.
Any questions?
All right.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Do you
want Sam to cover this?
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Yeah.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Just a quick word
about the resources
we have for web developers.
Justin's already mentioned
the reference video chat
app, AppRTC.
Like you said, as well as a
stack of work on the back end
stuff, we're working on
improving the UI/UX for that
particularly, so
it will work really
well across multiple devices.
And also a kind of optimizing
the JavaScript and so on.
We've moved the
reference WebRTC samples
that are built by the
WebRTC team to GitHub.
And we really, really welcome
the patches and issues
that we're receiving for that.
So please, we'd love to see
your samples and anything
you're having problems
with with our samples.
And again, we've tried to build
all those-- kind of refactor
them so they work.
And the demos for all these
samples via GitHub pages,
on that site.
And they have refactored
in order to work on mobile.
We also have, for people who
are learning about WebRTC,
we maintain a code lab, which is
currently on big bucket there.
And I also maintain this
giant list of everything
to do with WebRTC.
So check that out and please
feel free to add to that.
We have, obviously, Google+.
WebRTC with that.
And there's the big
bucket code lab.
And just one last thing.
As you can see from the
numbers on these I/O videos,
there is incredible
interest that we
find from-- from our
perspective-- there's
incredible interest in WebRTC,
relative to other APIs,
I think.
So if you're doing
WebRTC stuff, I
think you're in
the right business.
JUSTIN UBERTI: The 2012 video
is the number five most watched
video of all Google
I/O, for WebRTC.
And the one for 2013
was the number 3.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Let's
see what we get this year.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah.
Well, you know.
It's--
SERGE LACHAPELLE: And this is
an interesting thing, right?
We did a little gather
up like this in January,
and we had about 30,
35 people show up.
And today, we didn't
have Chris helping us.
So it's amazing to
see the interest.
Now I think I'm going to
attack the agenda a little bit,
because we went a
little bit over time.
What we're going to do is we're
going to go past the question
section, and we're
going to come back
to the questions after the
break and after the demos,
so that those of you that
need to leave can leave,
and those of you who are
interested in listening to us
answer these
questions can do that.
And so we don't
cut into the time
of the people that prepared
demos for us today.
Is that OK?
JUSTIN UBERTI: One more thing?
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Yep.
JUSTIN UBERTI: So
we've seen great uptake
from people actually shipping
real applications this year.
Already in 2014, we've
seen Snapchat roll out,
with WebRTC-based video chat.
And the Amazon
Mayday service, which
is also powered by WebRTC.
So it gives me great
pleasure to announce
that, starting today, Google
Hangouts is now rolling out
on WebRTC.
[APPLAUSE]
This is a long time coming.
And a number of
people asked, you guys
have been working on WebRTC,
why isn't this here yet?
We had a bunch of stuff to do.
For one, we transitioned from
a different codec to VP8.
That was a fair
pretty heavy forklift.
And we also wanted to
make sure that we didn't
regress any feature
functionality.
So this version of
Hangouts, based on WebRTC,
provides all the features
that you expect in Hangouts.
Including things
like screen sharing,
it includes Hangouts
video effects,
which is accomplished
using something
we do in Native Client for
video stream processing.
And it supports the whole
group video chat experience.
Hangouts on air, all that.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: It's
slowly rolling out.
If you install Chrome Beta.
Chrome dev, you're going
to most likely get it
off your Gmail account.
And if you're on
the Chrome's table,
we're slowly rolling it out.
And that roll-out is going
to take a little bit of time,
as we do these things carefully.
But give us feedback.
Install dev or beta
and give us feedback.